MARK: I'M MARK HALPERIN.
MARK: AND I'M MARK HALPERIN.
THIS IS A SPECIAL "FREAKY
FRIDAY" EDITION OF "WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT."
MARK AND I WILL BE HERE ALL
NIGHT, BUT THIS WEEKEND'S TOPICS
WERE SO BIG LEAGUE NO SINGLE
ANCHOR COULD POSSIBLY DO THE
JOB.
MARGARET IS IN OUR WASHINGTON
BUREAU.
WELCOME.
MARGARET: I'M MARK HALPERIN.
THANK YOU.
MARK: WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
A TRIO OF REPUBLICANS WHO HAD TO
DEAL ONE WAY OR ANOTHER WITH
DONALD TRUMP, BILLIONAIRE.
PAUL RYAN HAD A CAPITOL HILL
PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY WHERE
HE SAID HE HAS NO PLANS NOW TO
LONDON DOOR'S -- TO UNENDORSE
DONALD TRUMP.
ACCORDING TO OUR SOURCES, RYAN'S
CAREFULLY CHOSEN WORDS WERE
MEANT TO KEEP THAT DOOR AJAR.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT TRUMP IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH NBC NEWS' CHUCK
TODD THAT WILL AIR IN FULL ON
SUNDAY, RYAN TOLD FELLOW
REPUBLICANS TO RUN FOR THE HILLS
IF THEY WANT TO.
TODD: YOU THINK IT IS THAT
MEMBERS IN THE HOUSE, FOLLOW
YOUR CONSCIENCE.
SPEAKER RYAN: THE LAST THING I
REDUCE TELL ANYBODY TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS CONTRARY TO
THEIR CONSCIENCE.
THIS IS A VERY STRANGE
SITUATION.
THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE NOMINEE,
BUT I FEEL AS A RESPONSIBILITY
INSTITUTIONAL HE AS THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE THAT I SHOULD NOT
BE BUILDING SOME CHASM IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PARTY.
MARK: WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THE SPEAKER PASSWORDS TO
CHUCK TODD?
MARGARET: A VOTE OF CONSCIENCE,
AS WE TYPICALLY THINK OF IT, IS
A VOTE ON ABORTION OR GOING TO
WAR, NOT SUPPORTING THE NOMINEE
OF YOUR OWN PARTY.
HE IS SAYING IS TRUMP BECOMES A
BRIDGE TOO FAR, DETACHED FROM
HIM AND TRY TO SAVE THE SENATE.
IT HAS REALLY STUNNING
APPLICATIONS.
MARK: IT OPENS THE DOOR FOR
ANYBODY WITHOUT ANY FEAR THAT
THE SPEAKER WILL BE UNHAPPY.
I THINK IT OPENS THE DOOR TO THE
SPEAKER DOING THE SAME THING,
AND THIS MOVEMENT TO TRY TO
CHANGE THE RULES OF THE
CONVENTION TO TRY TO STOP NOW,
LEADING DELEGATES TELLING THEM
TO VOTE THEIR CONSCIENCE, SO
PAUL RYAN USING THOSE WORDS IS
LIKE A DOG WHISTLE.
IF YOU THINK VOTING FOR TRUMP AT
THE CONVENTION OR SUPPORTING
TRUMP IN THE FALL IS NOT IN YOUR
INTEREST, THE PARTY'S INTEREST,
OR THE COUNTRY'S INTEREST, BE MY
GUEST.
MARGARET: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
AND THE CONVENTION STRUCTURE IS
GOING TO FOLLOW IT.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
PIECES OF THIS COME TOGETHER IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
MARK: AGAIN, CHUCK'S INTERVIEW
WITH SPEAKER RYAN WITH LOTS MORE
ON TRUMP WILL AIR THIS SUNDAY ON
"MEET THE PRESS."
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW PEOPLE
REACT TO WHAT RYAN HAS SAID.
THAT BRINGS US TO OUR NEXT BIG
REPUBLICAN WHO HAD TO DEAL WITH
TRUMP, AT LEAST INDIRECTLY, THIS
WEEK, GEORGE W. BUSH.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS
DOING FUNDRAISING FOR EMBATTLED
SENATE CANDIDATES.
WE ARE HEARING THAT TRUMP'S
PULLING FREEFALL IS HAVING A
DELETERIOUS EFFECT ON THE
POLITICAL HEALTH OF DOWN BALLOT
CANDIDATES INCLUDING A LOT OF
SENATE CANDIDATES.
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS OF
DUBYA GETTING INVOLVED IN THIS
WAY?
MARGARET: IT IS GREAT FOR GEORGE
W. BUSH BECAUSE HE SPENT A FAIR
AMOUNT OF TIME IN EXILE KIND OF,
PARTLY OF HIS OWN DOING, WAITING
FOR HIS LEGACY AND REPUTATION TO
SETTLE IN A BETTER WAY THAN WHEN
HE LEFT OFFICE, AND THIS ALLOWS
HIM TO COME IN AND POTENTIALLY
AVENGE WHAT HAPPENED TO HIS
BROTHER AND SOLIDIFY A NAME FOR
HIMSELF IF HE IS ABLE TO HELP
THESE REPUBLICANS WHO ARE IN
TROUBLE.
IT DOES CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
HE IS APPEALING TO THE MIDDLE,
TO THE OLD GUARD, TO THE CENTER,
TO THE ESTABLISHMENT, BUT IF
THERE ARE ENOUGH TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE TURNED OFF BY
SOME OF THESE FOLKS AND DO NOT
WANT TO VOTE FOR THEM, THAT
COULD BE A PROBLEM FOR GEORGE W.
BUSH BEING THE CROSS PARTY
APPEAL TO INDEPENDENT VOTERS.
MARK: IN SOME WAYS, THIS COULD
HELP TRUMP, BUT WHEN HE SPEAKS
AT THESE EVENTS, THE SYMBOLISM
CREATE THIS TWO REPUBLICAN
PARTY'S, THE BUS ESTABLISHMENT
WING AND THE TRUMP WING -- THE
BUSH ESTABLISHMENT WING AND THE
TRUMP WING, AND THESE CANDIDATES
CLEARLY ARE GOING TO BE MORE
DRAWN TO BUSH THAN TO TRUMP.
ALTHOUGH TRUMP SAYS HE IS FINE
WITH IT, THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING THAT SHOWS MORE DIVISION.
BUSH IS ALONG WITH MITT ROMNEY
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT PEOPLE
SAYING THEY WILL NOT SHOW UP AT
THE CONVENTION, BUT IT DOES GET
ONE OF THEIR BIGGEST FUNDRAISERS
BACK IN THE FIELD AND TAKE SOME
PRESSURE OFF OF TRUMP TO TRY TO
RAISE MONEY OFF OF THESE SENATE
CANDIDATES.
THEY ARE ALL DESPERATE TO RAISE
AS MUCH AS THEY CAN.
BUSH HAS BEEN OFF THE FIELD FOR
SO LONG HE STILL HAS A PRETTY
STRONG NETWORK AND ALL THESE
STATES WHERE HE IS TRYING TO
HELP THESE CANDIDATES.
MARGARET: IT DOES FURTHER THESE
DIVISIONS.
MARK: ONE LAST BIG REPUBLICAN
WHO GOT ENTANGLED WITH TRUMP
THIS WEEK IS ONE OF THOSE SENATE
REPUBLICANS WHO IS EMBATTLED.
JOHN MCCAIN YESTERDAY TOLD
REPORTERS THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
IS "DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE" FOR
THE MASS SHOOTING IN ORLANDO
BECAUSE OF POLICIES THAT ALLOW
THE RISE OF THE ISLAMIC STATE.
WHEN THAT REMARK WAS COMPARED BY
SOME TO THE RHETORIC OF TRUMP
AND HIS CAMPAIGN, MCCAIN WALKED
IT BACK AND PUT OUT A STATEMENT
THAT SAID IN PART, "I DID NOT
MEAN TO IMPLY THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE.
I WAS REFERRING TO PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S NATIONAL SECURITY
DECISIONS, NOT THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF."
THAT WALKED BACK DID NOT STOP
THE STORY FROM REVERBERATING IN
ARIZONA.
HERE IS WHAT THE SENATOR WOKE UP
TO ON LOCAL TV.
>> SENATOR JOHN MCCAIN IS
CLARIFYING COMMENTS HE MADE
ABOUT THE ORLANDO MASS SHOOTING
BLAMING PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> SENATOR JOHN MCCAIN WALKING
THAT COMMENTS HE MADE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE ORLANDO TERROR
ATTACK.
>> EDITOR MCCAIN BACKTRACKING ON
A BOLD STATEMENT --
>> BACKPEDALING ON OLD
STATEMENTS HE MADE --
BACKPEDALING ON BOLD STATEMENTS
HE MADE.
>> SENATOR KIRKPATRICK SAYING HE
SAW JOHN MCCAIN ACROSS A
DANGEROUS LINE IN COMMENTS THAT
UNDERMINE OUR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
ON NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES.
MARK: WHAT LESSONS CAN WE LEARN
ABOUT THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
STATE OF THE PARTY FROM JOHN
MCCAIN'S SITUATION HERE?
MARGARET: WE HAVE SEEN THIS
BEFORE TO SOME EXTENT.
THERE ARE SOME SITUATIONS WHERE
JOHN MCCAIN IS HIS WORST ENEMY,
AND THIS WOULD BE ONE OF THESE
TIMES.
IT HAS BEEN AWFUL TO WATCH THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS WITH THE
POSITION HE FEELS HE HAS BEEN
FORCED INTO.
THE PRESIDENT WAS HOPE IN A --
HOPING HE WOULD ACCOMPANY HIM TO
HISTORY IT -- ON HIS TRIP TO
VIETNAM, AND HE COULD NOT DO
THAT.
JOHN MCCAIN, THE 2008 NOMINEE
FOR HIS PARTY, IS NOW REALLY IN
A LOT OF TROUBLE, AND TRUMP HAS
GOT HIM IN A REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE POSITION BECAUSE
HE DISAGREES JUST INSTINCTIVELY
WITH SO MUCH OF WHAT TRUMP IS
DOING, AND HE CANNOT HELP
HIMSELF FROM GETTING HALFWAY
THERE SOMETIMES.
TRUMP IS DRAGGING HIM DOWN WITH
THAT PART OF THE VOTE.
MARK: THERE'S NO DOUBT THERE ARE
A LOT OF VOTERS JOHN MCCAIN
NEEDS TO VOTE FOR HIM WHO LIKE
TRUMP.
AT THE SAME TIME, JOHN MCCAIN
SAYS THIS KIND OF STUFF ALL THE
TIME.
NOT ONLY DO THEY NEED TO COMMENT
ON WHAT TRUMP SAYS, BUT THE
PRESS AND DEMOCRATS ARE ON HIGH
ALERT FOR CONTROVERSIAL
STATEMENTS, SAYING THINGS THAT
ARE LIKE WHAT TRUMP SAYS, IN
THIS CASE PRETTY SPECIFICALLY
CLOSE TO WHAT TRUMP SAYS, AND
THAT MEANS THEY ARE GOING TO
LOSE SOME NEWS CYCLES BECAUSE
WHEN THEY MAKE MISTAKES, THEY
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IF YOU WALK
BACK OR APOLOGIZE FOR LIKE TRUMP
DOES, BOLD THROUGH IT -- BULL
THROUGH IT.
MCCAIN WILL NOT BE THE LAST ONE
FACING THOSE HEADLINES.
MARGARET: BACK PEDDLING IS NOT
WHAT YOU WANT THE HEADLINE TO
SAY.
MARK: AND MCCAIN CANNOT LIKE THE
HEADLINE HE SEES IN FRONT OF
HIM.
TRUMP CLEARLY NOT GETTING ANY
LIFELINES FROM THE REPUBLICANS
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
AT THIS POINT, IS THERE ANYBODY
OUT THERE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHO, IF THEY DECIDED THEY
WANTED TO HELP STOP THIS TRUMP
SLIDE -- BESIDES TRUMP HIMSELF
AND THE PEOPLE WORKING FOR HIM
-- IS THERE ANYBODY WHO CAN TURN
THE NARRATIVE AROUND?
MARGARET: THE KEY IS WHAT YOU
JUST SAID -- IF THEY WANTED TO.
THERE ARE WOMEN IN THE REPUBLIC
OF HISPANICS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, HISPANIC WOMEN IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PARTY, BUT THE
PROBLEM IS EVERY TIME THEY SORT
OF MAKE THEIR PEACE WITH GETTING
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT HE DOES,
HE WILL COME OUT AND SAY
SOMETHING LIKE WHAT WE JUST SAW.
GOVERNORS FROM KEY STATES,
ESPECIALLY FEMALE GOVERNORS, ARE
PROBABLY HIS BEST BET AT THIS
POINT.
MARK: TRUMP REACHING OUT TO
GOVERNORS, TRYING TO GET
SUPPORT, THINKING THAT THEY CAN
FROM, IN SOME WAY -- PUN
INTENDED -- MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
-- THEY CAN TRUMP, IN SOME WAY
-- PUN INTENDED -- MAKERS OF
CONGRESS.
THERE WAS A PUSH FOR PEOPLE TO
SAY STOP CRITICIZING TRUMP.
THIS IS OUR PARTY.
THAT MOVEMENT, AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL, IS DEAD.
EVERYONE IS WORRIED THEY WILL
COME OUT AND SAY THAT IN THE
NEXT THING THAT WILL HAPPEN IS
HE WILL DO SOMETHING THEY WILL
FEEL THE NEED TO REPUDIATE AND
THEY WILL NOT BE IN A POSITION
TO BE SCOLDING OTHER REPUBLICANS
FOR NOT BEING FULL THROATED IN
THEIR SUPPORT.
MARGARET: AN ABSOLUTE FREEFALL
OVER THE LAST WEEK AND A HALF OR
SO.
MARK: WE AGREE IT IS UNLIKELY,
BUT IF TRUMP COULD TAP ANY ONE
PERSON IN THE PARTY ON THE
SHOULDER AND SAY THEY NEED TO
COME OUT FOR HANDFUL FULL
THROATED, WHO DO YOU THINK WOULD
BE THE MOST HELPFUL, LEAVING
ASIDE THE FACT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO?
MARGARET: RIGHT, BECAUSE PAUL
RYAN.
PARTY ESTABLISHMENT OR PERHAPS
FEMALE GOVERNORS.
I'M STUMPED.
YOU KEEP HEARING THE NAME OF
NEWT GINGRICH.
HOW DOES THAT REACH ACROSS THE
BRIDGE, REACH WOMEN, REACH
INDEPENDENT VOTERS?
MARK: VERY TOUGH SITUATION.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE BRING IN
ANOTHER GUEST HOST AND TALK MORE
TRUMP, TRUMP, TRUMP.
WE TALKED OUR WEEK OF
DISSENSION, DATA, AND DONORS
AFTER THIS WORD FROM OUR
SPONSORS.
♪
MARK: TWO DAYS AGO, WE USED THE
FAMOUS THREE D'S TO CATALOG
DONALD TRUMP'S TRAVAIL --
DISSENSION, DATA, AND DONORS.
WE WILL BE CHECKING IN ON THAT
WITH NBC'S KATIE COURIC, WHO IS
HERE TO LEND A HAND IN THIS
BLOCK.
NBC AND POLITICO BOTH REPORTED
THERE IS TENSION NOW BETWEEN THE
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
SENT OUT THIS VERY TRUMP-IAN TW
EET --
EVEN INCLUDED THE EXCLAMATION
POINT.
THE RNC ANNOUNCED HALEY BARBOUR
WILL HEAD UP THE CONVENTION
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE NEXT
MONTH, AND UTAH, WHICH WAS ONE
OF TRUMP'S FIRST -- WORST STATES
, THEIR GOVERNOR WILL CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT IS THE STATE OF PLAY
BETWEEN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
IS THERE DISSENSION ABOVE THE
NORM OR AT THE NORM?
KATIE: THAT RHINCE TWEET WAS
VERY INTERESTING.
DIDN'T IT SOUND JUST LIKE DONALD
TRUMP?
THAT WAS CERTAINLY A PUBLIC
SHOWING OF SUPPORT FROM THE
CHAIRMAN TO HIS NOMINEE, BUT WE
HAD SIX DIFFERENT SOURCES THAT
DESCRIBED WHAT HAS BEEN INTERIOR
READING TRUST BETWEEN THE TWO
SIDES AND TENSIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILDING, EACH ONE THINKING
THAT THE OTHER IS ONLY OUT OR
THEMSELVES.
THE RNC -- AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS SO MANY TIMES --
ENCOURAGING AND TRYING TO GET
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS TEAM TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE.
THAT NOT HAPPENING.
THEY STILL DO NOT HAVE A
COMMUNICATION TEAM IN PLACE.
USUALLY, THE COMMUNICATION TEAM
WILL AT LEAST MATCH THE RNC WHEN
IT COMES TO STAFFING UP IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES, BUT DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS TEAM ESSENTIALLY
JUST RELYING ON THE RNC TO
BOLSTER THEM INSTEAD OF FINDING
A WAY TO WORK TOGETHER AND TO
BUILD OUT AN EFFECTIVE PLAN.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, FOR ITS
PART, WE SHOULD SAY, DENIES THIS
REPORT, SAYS THAT THEY HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE RNC.
MARK: I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE INCREASED TENSION.
A LOT OF DECISIONS TO BE MADE.
YOU ALWAYS SEE THAT TENSION
BETWEEN THE NATIONAL PARTY AND A
NOMINEE TEAM ABOUT PLANNING THE
CONVENTION, BUT AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, THERE ARE A LOT OF DECISIONS
TO BE MADE, AND THE FRICTION
OVER THOSE THINGS IS GROWING
PRETTY HIGH AS WELL.
SOME PEOPLE AT THE RNC WANT
EVERYTHING TO BE FRIENDLY, BUT
AS YOU JUST SAID, NOT EVERYBODY
THINKS IT IS SO FRIENDLY RIGHT
NOW.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT D, DATA.
NATIONAL POLLING CONTINUES TO
SUGGEST DONALD TRUMP IS IN SOME
TROUBLE.
THE PRESUMPTIVE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE, FORMERLY THE BRAG OR IN
CHIEF WHEN IT CAME TO HIS POLE
STANDING, HAS NOW TAKEN TO
DENOUNCING THE POLLS, AS HE DID
LAST NIGHT IN DALLAS.
HOW BIG A PROBLEM IS IT FOR
TRUMP THAT HE CAN NO LONGER GO
TO HIS RALLIES AND TALK ABOUT
HOW HE IS WINNING?
KATIE: WE WILL HAVE TO SEE.
HE DID SAY IN ATLANTA THE OTHER
NIGHT -- HE TALKED ABOUT THESE
PHONY POLLS, WHICH WAS THE DAY A
NUMBER OF REALLY BAD POLLS CAME
OUT AGAINST HIM.
TODAY TO MAGGIE HABERMAN, HE
ADMITTED FOR, I THINK THE FIRST
TIME THAT HE IS DOWN IN THE
POLLS, SO IT IS AN
UNCHARACTERISTIC SELF-AWARENESS
FROM THE CANDIDATE, WHICH DOES
SEEM TO POINT TO HIM ACTUALLY
REALIZING THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
I THINK THAT'S WHY WE SOUGHT
MAYBE A MORE MODERATED SPEECH
FROM HIM IN DALLAS LAST NIGHT,
BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE, AND THE
CAMPAIGN KNOWS IT IS AN ISSUE,
BUT DONALD TRUMP SEEMS TO BE
SAYING THAT HE DOES NOT BELIEVE
HE IS GOING TO BE DOING POORLY
WHEN IT COMES TO, YOU KNOW,
AUGUST, SEPTEMBER.
REMEMBER, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
ARE THE UNDERDOGS, REGARDLESS OF
HOW THEY DID IN THE PRIMARY.
MARK:  THE PUBLIC POLLING ON THE
HORSE RACE GETS THIS KIND OF
ATTENTION, BUT TWO DIFFERENT
SETS OF DATA CONTINUE TO BE
PROBLEMATIC FOR REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE WORRIED ABOUT TRUMP AT THE
TOP OF THE TICKET.
ONE IS HIS UNFAVORABLY RATING.
NOT JUST OVERALL BUT WITH SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT GROUPS.
THIS IS AN ELECTION THAT WILL
NOT BE WON SOLELY ON THE BACKS
OF WHITE MEN.
THE PROBLEM IS WITH ALL THE
OTHER DATA, AND ALL PAST
CANDIDATES WHO COULD AFFORD
PULLING ARE GOING INTO THE FIELD
AND FINDING THAT TRUMP IS
HURTING THEM.
IT IS FOCUSING THE MIND OF MITCH
MCCONNELL, OF PAUL RYAN, AND OF
THEIR DONORS AND OF THEIR
POLITICAL ADVISERS WHO ARE
ASKING IF THIS WILL REALLY BE
THERE EIGHT, TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THIS PROBLEM?
CAN TRUMP TURN IT AROUND?
MAYBE, BUT THEY ARE INCREASINGLY
PESSIMISTIC THAT HE CAN, AND IF
HE DOES NOT, THAT THEY CAN
SURVIVE TRUMP HAVING THE KIND OF
NUMBERS THAT HE HAS WITH THE
CLINTON AS AGAINST HIM JUST
BEGINNING.
FINALLY, THE DONOR CLASS.
TRUMP IS IN TEXAS CONTINUING ON
A DONOR TOUR.
HE IS IN HOUSTON CAPPING OFF A
WEEK OF FUNDRAISERS IF HE WENT
TO GEORGIA, NORTH CAROLINA, AND
TEXAS, AND NEXT WEEK HE WILL BE
HERE IN GOTHAM CITY WITH SOME
BIG NAMES LIKE PRIVATE EQUITY
INVESTOR STEPHEN FEINBERG AND
REAL ESTATE MAGNATE PETER COWGER
.
TRUMP SEEMS TO BE DOING A LOT OF
FUNDRAISING.
HAS HE SOLVED HIS DONOR PROBLEM?
KATIE: HE HAS NOT YET, BUT WE
ARE TOLD LAST NIGHT FROM A FEW
SOURCES THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
RAISE ABOUT $6 MILLION, WHICH IS
A GOOD HAUL FOR ONE NIGHT IN
DALLAS.
WHEN MITT ROMNEY WAS THERE, HE
ONLY RAISED ABOUT $3.4 MILLION,
BUT LET'S BE REALISTIC -- HE
DOES SO FAR BEHIND WHEN MITT
ROMNEY WAS BACK IN 2012, SO FAR
BEHIND WHERE HILLARY CLINTON
WAS.
MITT ROMNEY WAS RAISING I THINK
$100 MILLION A MONTH AT ONE
POINT.
HILLARY CLINTON ALREADY RAISING
TONS OF MONEY RIGHT NOW.
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN HAS A
STEEP HILL TO CLIMB.
WHAT THEY DO HAVE ON THEIR SIDE
IS A CHANGE IN THE RULES.
NOW INDIVIDUAL DONORS CAN GET
ABOUT THREE TIMES AS MUCH AS
THEY WERE ABLE TO GIVE IN 2012.
$97,000 AS OPPOSED TO $32,000.
HE ONLY NEEDS TO RELY ON A
SMALLER AMOUNT OF PEOPLE TO GIVE
A LARGER AMOUNT OF MONEY.
MARK: THAT RULE CHANGE WILL
CLEARLY HELP WITH HARD DOLLARS.
WHAT ASTOUNDS ME AS THERE ARE 10
OF AREAS WHERE TRUMP COULD BE
RAISING BIG MONEY WHERE I DO NOT
SEE ANY INDICATION THAT HE IS.
THEY STILL HAVE NOT DESIGNATED A
SUPER PAC THAT THEY CONSIDER TO
BE THERE GO TO, AND THE OTHER IS
SMALL DOLLARS.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT,
AND IF THEY DO NOT, THEY WILL BE
LEAVING A LOT OF MONEY ON THE
TABLE.
THE OTHER IS SMALL DOLLARS.
BERNIE SANDERS SHOWED YOU COULD
RAISE A TON OF MONEY ON THE
INTERNET JUST BY GOING ON TV AND
ASKING.
TRUMP HAS GRASSROOTS SUPPORT.
PEOPLE WRITE LETTERS.
WHY THEY ARE NOT OUT THERE
RAISING BIG MONEY AND BRAGGING
ABOUT IT IS BEYOND ME BECAUSE
THAT IS AN AREA, AS YOU
SUGGESTED, RIGHT ON MESSAGE
WHERE THEY COULD RAISE A LOT
MORE.
KATIE: THE PROBLEM IS THE IDEA
HE WILL GO OUT AND BLESS A SUPER
PAC GOES COUNTER TO EVERYTHING
HE SAID DURING THE PRIMARY.
I ALSO THINK IT IS COUNTER TO
DONALD TRUMP AS A BUSINESSMAN.
HE DOES NOT LIKE TO GO OUT AND
ASK FOR MONEY IN THAT WAY, BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO SMALLER DONORS,
I THINK YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THEY RELIED ON THEM IN THE
PRIMARIES.
WHY ARE THEY NOT TOUTING HOW
MUCH MONEY THEY ARE MAKING?
IT MAKES YOU WONDER.
MAYBE THEY ARE NOT MAKING MUCH.
MARK: NEXT, WE WILL BRING IN OUR
LAST GUEST HOST TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT BERNIE SANDERS SAID LAST
NIGHT AND, MORE IMPORTANTLY,
WHAT HE HAS ACHIEVED ALREADY.
♪
MARK: LAST NIGHT, BERNIE SANDERS
MADE A LIVE ONLINE VIDEO ADDRESS
TO SUPPORTERS.
HE DID NOT DROP OUT OF THE RACE
OFFICIALLY OR SUPPORT HILLARY
CLINTON AND HE DID NOT MAKE HIS
POSTURE FOR PHILADELPHIA NEXT
MONTH  MUCH CLEARER.
CENTERS: THE TASK WE FACE IN THE
NEXT FIVE MONTHS IS TO MAKE SURE
DONALD TRUMP IS DEFEATED AND
DEFEATED BADLY.
I PERSONALLY INTEND TO BEGIN MY
ROLE IN THAT PROCESS IN A VERY
SHORT TIME, BUT DEFEATING DONALD
TRUMP CANNOT BE OUR ONLY GOAL.
WE MUST CONTINUE OUR GRASSROOTS
EFFORT TO CREATE THE AMERICA
THAT WE KNOW WE CAN BECOME, AND
WE MUST TAKE THAT ENERGY INTO
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION ON JULY 25 IN
PHILADELPHIA, WHERE WE WILL HAVE
MORE THAN 1900 DELEGATES.
MARK: MSNBC'S POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT CASEY HUNT JOINS
US AS OUR THIRD GUEST HOST.
HE HAS A LEGACY, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT HE INS AT DOING IN
PHILADELPHIA.
LET'S TALK FIRST ABOUT POLICY.
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT DO YOU THINK
HE HAS HAD AND IS HAVING?
KASIE: I THINK HE CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE IS AN
APPETITE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WANTED TO
COME OUT AND SAID OR A LOT OF
THESE REFORMS THAT HE HAS BEEN
PUSHING FORWARD ON ECONOMIC
POLICY.
FOR EXAMPLE, MINIMUM WAGE,
HEALTH CARE, SINGLE CARE --
SINGLE-PAYER HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL, FREE COLLEGE TUITION -- OF
COURSE, THESE ARE IDEAS THAT
GENERATED RIDICULE FROM PEOPLE
INSIDE THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WHO
SAID THESE ARE ALL TYPE DREAMS.
HE SAYS HE DOES NOT KNOW HOW TO
PAY FOR IT, BUT CLEARLY, PEOPLE
WERE RESPONDING.
THE SECOND THING I THINK THAT
WAS A HUGE PART OF HIS STUMP
SPEECH AND VERY MOTIVATING FOR A
LOT OF THESE YOUNG SUPPORTERS
WAS CAMPAIGN-FINANCE REFORM AND
THE OF -- THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE
TO BUY INTO HIS CAMPAIGN IN
SMALL AMOUNTS, AND HIS ARGUMENT
THAT THAT WAS A FUNDAMENTAL
POLICY CHANGE THAT IN HIS VIEW
COULD REALLY RESHAPE A SICKLY
THE ENTIRE POLITICAL SYSTEM AS
IT CURRENTLY EXISTS.
-- RESHAPE BASICALLY THE ENTIRE
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
I THINK THE TOP LINE IS ACTUALLY
ON THIS ISSUE OF FINANCE REFORM.
IT IS A POLICY PRIORITY THAT
COULD BE ADDRESSED WITH
LEGISLATION.
HE CERTAINLY WANTS TO DO THAT,
BUT HE PROVED BY THE CAMPAIGN
THAT HE RAN THAT IT IS POSSIBLE
TO MOUNT A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
HE OUTRAISED HILLARY CLINTON
WITHOUT HAVING BIG DONORS.
HAVING COVERED HIM FOR MONTHS,
AS YOU KNOW, COVERING
FUNDRAISERS IS A BIG PART
TYPICALLY OF BEING OUT ON THE
ROAD WITH A CANDIDATE, AND WE
NEVER WENT TO FUNDRAISERS HARDLY
WITH ERNIE SANDERS, AND I THINK
THAT WAS A SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
CHANGE.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: OUR NEXT GUEST IS A
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST AND MITT
ROMNEY'S 2012 CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
KATIE PACKARD JOINS US FROM
WASHINGTON.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE'S A FAIR
AMOUNT OF CHATTER ABOUT SOME
DELEGATES AT THE CONVENTION
TRYING TO OVERCOME THE OBSTACLES
TO GETTING RULES CHANGES TO KEEP
DONALD TRUMP FROM BEING THE
NOMINEE.
FROM A RULES PERSPECTIVE, NOT A
PR PERSPECTIVE, WHAT IS YOUR
SENSE OF HOW POSSIBLE THAT IS?
KATIE: I THINK IT IS REALLY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE RULES THAT
APPLY TO THIS CONVENTION ARE
ACTUALLY MADE AT THIS
CONVENTION.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS UP UNTIL
THEN IS KIND OF A GUIDELINE MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
THERE IS A REAL POSSIBILITY,
ACCORDING TO A LOT OF EXPERTS
THAT HAVE REALLY PAID CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THIS THAT THERE
REALLY IS NO SUCH THING AS BOUND
DELEGATES, THAT ONCE THE
DELEGATES GET THERE, THEY CAN
VOTE TO CHANGE THE RULES AND
DETERMINE IF THEY WANT PEOPLE TO
BE BOUND BY WHAT HAPPENED IN
THEIR HOME STATES OR NOT.
I DO THINK THIS IS A PROCESS
THAT WILL HAVE TO ORIGINATE WITH
DELEGATES AND NOT WITH
WASHINGTON.
MARK: THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCED THAT THE
NATIONAL COMMITTEEWOMAN FROM
UTAH WILL HEAD THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND HALEY BARBOUR WILL
PLAY A ROLE AT THE CONVENTION
MANAGING THE FLOOR TO SOME
EXTENT WHEN PAUL RYAN IS NOT
DOING IT.
BASED ON YOUR KNOWLEDGE, OR TEA
LEAF READING, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THOSE DECISIONS?
KATIE: BOTH ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME,
KNOW THE PROCESS, KNOW WHAT GOES
ON AT A CONVENTION, AND I DO
THINK THERE HAS BEEN CONCERNED
THAT A LOT OF THE FOLKS TRUMP IS
INVOLVING OUR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ENGAGED IN ANY REAL WAY
IN SUCH A LONG TIME THAT THEY
REALLY DID NEED TO HAVE SOME
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE THAT IS
A LITTLE MORE CURRENT.
BOTH OF THOSE FOLKS ARE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED THE LAST
SEVERAL CONVENTIONS IN SOME WAY,
SO I THINK IT DOES BRING, YOU
KNOW, SOME SORT OF BOLSTER WITH
THE RNC NEEDS TO KEEP CONTROL OF
THE CONVENTION.
MARK: I TAKE YOUR POINT THAT
THIS IS MORE LIKELY TO BE
EFFECTIVE IF IT IS ORGANIC AND
GRASSROOTS FROM THE DELEGATES,
BUT MOST REPUBLICANS THAT I
TALKED TO SAY THE MOVE WILL NOT
HAPPEN UNLESS MITCH MCCONNELL
AND PAUL RYAN GET BEHIND IT.
IF YOU AGREE WITH THAT OR NOT,
IF MITCH MCCONNELL CALLS YOU UP
AND DOES, "MAKE YOUR BEST CASE
FOR WHY I SHOULD RISK GOING
AGAINST THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
AND PUT MY INFLUENCE BEHIND
TRYING TO CHANGE THE RULES AND
GO AGAINST TRUMP," WHAT IS YOUR
PITCH?
KATIE: I DO THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
ORGANIC.
MAYBE IT WOULD HAVE THE BLESSING
OF PEOPLE LIKE MITCH MCCONNELL
AND PAUL RYAN, BUT I DO THINK IT
WOULD BE A BAD THING FOR THEM TO
IN ANY WAY APPEAR AS THOUGH THEY
ARE LEADING THIS CHARGE.
DONALD TRUMP DID WIN THESE
PRIMARIES, BUT A LOT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE THEN.
USUALLY I LOVE BEING RIGHT.
THIS IS ONE CASE WHERE I REALLY
TAKE NO PLEASURE IN BEING RIGHT,
BUT THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
PREDICTED IN THE SPRING WHAT
HAPPENED, THAT DONALD TRUMP
WOULD BE A DISASTER FOR OUR
PARTY.
HE WOULD NOT CHANGE.
HE IS SORT OF JOHNNY ONE NOTE,
ONLY KNOWS HOW TO BE ONE WAY,
AND IT IS PROVING TO BE
DISASTROUS FOR OUR PARTY.
IF HE HAS ANOTHER COUPLE OF
WEEKS LIKE THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, THE DELEGATES AND THE
LEADERS OF THE PARTY ARE GOING
TO REALLY START TO TALK IN
EARNEST ABOUT WHAT WE DO COME
CLEVELAND.
MARK: IT WAS NOT THAT LONG AGO
HILLARY CLINTON WAS HAVING SOME
THAT WEEKS.
MICHAEL DUKAKIS WAS UP 17 POINTS
IN THE SUMMER.
ARE YOU RULING OUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT TRUMP COULD
START PERFORMING BETTER AND WIN
THIS?
KATIE: THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP AND ANY OF THESE
OTHER CANDIDATES IS OTHER
CANDIDATES HAVE PROVEN TO BE
WILLING TO LISTEN TO SOUND
ADVICE AND COUNSEL.
WHEN THEY HAVE IT DOWN, THEY
HAVE SORT OF REVAMPED THEIR
STRATEGY AND DECIDED TO GO A
DIFFERENT WAY.
DONALD TRUMP IS 70 YEARS OLD.
I DO NOT THINK HE IS GOING TO
WHOLESALE CHANGE HIS STRATEGY
AND HE ONLY KNOWS HOW TO
CAMPAIGN TO A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION AND THOSE ARE NOT
THE VOTERS WE NEED TO GET OVER
THE TOP.
HE CLEARLY HAS SUPPORTERS LOCKED
IN.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GO
ANYWHERE, BUT YOU HAVE SEEN THE
VERY HIGH DISAPPROVAL RATINGS
THAT HE HAS.
55% OF AMERICAN VOTERS THIS WEEK
SAID THAT THEY WOULD NEVER VOTE
OR TRUMP.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
THIS IS CATASTROPHIC, AND IF
SOMETHING DOES NOT CHANGE, IT IS
GOING TO BE REALLY DEVASTATING.
MARK: WHO ARE THE MOST LIKELY
VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEES AT
THIS POINT?
KATIE: THAT IS A REALLY TOUGH
THING.
MY MONEY IS ON DONALD TRUMP
CONTINUING TO BE THE NOMINEE,
EVEN THOUGH IT WILL BE A VERY
TOUGH THING FOR OUR PARTY, BUT I
THINK SEVERAL OF THE CANDIDATES
THAT RAN THIS YEAR WOULD BE
PLAUSIBLE OPTIONS.
CERTAINLY SOMEONE LIKE JOHN
KASICH, TED CRUZ, MARCO RUBIO --
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE THAT SORT
OF INTEREST STRONG, SECOND,
THIRD, FOURTH PLACES.
ANY OF THESE CANDIDATES I THINK
WOULD BE STRONGER IN A GENERAL
ELECTION, AND HAD THEY WON, I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO RALLY AROUND
ANY OF THE OTHER CANDIDATES, BUT
DONALD TRUMP IS SORT OF A UNIQUE
BIRD.
WE HAVE A VERY WEAK OPPOSITION
IN HILLARY CLINTON, THE MOST
VULNERABLE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
PROBABLY IN SEVERAL DECADES, AND
WE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO NOMINATE
THE ONE GUY THAT COULD
UNDERPERFORM HER, SO ANY OF
THOSE CANDIDATES WOULD BE
STRONGER.
MARK: THE ONLY WAY SOMEBODY IS
THE NOMINEE BESIDES TRUMP'S WITH
A FAIR AMOUNT OF CHAOS AND
CLEVELAND.
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
TODAY, PEOPLE TALK ABOUT PAUL
RYAN, THEY TALK ABOUT A
RYAN/RUBIO TICKET OR A CASE OF
-- KASICH/RUBIO TICKET.
VOTERS WOULD GO CRAZY.
IS THERE A WAY FOR THAT SCENARIO
TO PLAY OUT IN THE CONVENTION IS
NOT JUST A HUGE MESS AND BAD FOR
THE PARTY?
>> IS SOMETHING LIKE THAT WERE
TO HAPPEN, OF COURSE THE
CONVENTION WOULD BE CHAOTIC.
THE QUESTION IS -- DO THE
DELEGATES IN CLEVELAND DECIDE
THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO GO DOWN
WITH THE SHIP OR ARE THEY GOING
TO STAND UP AND TRY TO EVENT
THAT?
LIKE I SAID, I DO NOT THINK
TODAY THAT IS LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
I DO THINK IF THERE IS A COUPLE
MORE WEEKS LIKE THIS LAST WEEK,
I DO THINK THE ENVIRONMENT COULD
BE CREATED WHERE PEOPLE SAY
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS HE IS BETTER
THAN HILLARY IS NOT A COMPELLING
MESSAGE FOR A GENERAL ELECTION,
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING
TO REALIZE THAT THAT IS THE ONLY
THING THAT THEY CAN SAY THAT IN
ANY WAY RESEMBLES, YOU KNOW, A
REASON -- A COMPELLING REASON
FOR REPUBLICANS TO SUPPORT TRUMP
.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO GET VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH THIS.
MARK: I KNOW YOU HAVE THOUGHT
LONG AND HARD AT VARIOUS STAGES
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE.
GIVEN THAT YOU ARE PRETTY
CONFIDENT TRUMP WILL BE THE
NOMINEE, HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
THINGS TO PLAY OUT THAT WOULD BE
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE PARTY
IN THE COUNTRY?
KATIE: I DO THINK THAT CANDIDATE
THAT ALLOW SOME DISTANCE BETWEEN
THEN AND TRUMP ARE THE SMART
CANDIDATES COME FALL.
CANDIDATES THAT EMBRACE HIM TOO
CLOSELY ARE EMBRACING A TICKING
TIME BOMB, AND IN TERMS OF DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO HOLD ONTO THE
SENATE WITH VERY, VERY STRONG
CANDIDATES, PROVIDING SOME LEVEL
OF ARM'S-LENGTH DISTANCE SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERYTHING HE SAYS AND WE TRY TO
HOLD ONTO THESE DOWN BALLOT
SEATS, THAT MAY BE THE BEST WE
CAN HOPE FOR.
MARK: THANKS VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
UP NEXT, MORE ON THE REPUBLICANS
RUNNING DOWN BALLOT FROM TRUMP.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO THIS PROGRAM
ON THE RADIO ANY TIME AT
BLOOMBERG 99.1 FM.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: COMING TO US NOW FROM THE
CITY OF THE DIAMONDBACKS,
PHOENIX, ARIZONA, THE NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR "THE
ARIZONA REPUBLIC," WHO COVERS
JOHN MCCAIN CLOSELY, DAN, WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE ON HOW JOHN MCCAIN
HAS BEHAVED IN THE PAST WHAT HE
AND HOURS AND HOW MUCH OF THAT
IS IN THE SHADOW OF DONALD AND
HIS REELECTION -- HOW'D JOHN
MCCAIN HAS BEHAVED IN THE PAST
48 HOURS?
DAN: A BIG PART OF THE ARIZONA
REPUBLICAN PARTY VIEWS HIM AS
TOO LIBERAL.
ON THE ONE HAND, HE LIKES TO
LOOK TOUGH AGAINST PRESIDENT
OBAMA, AND ONE OF THE WAYS HE
DOES THAT IS HE TAKES ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA HARD ON NATIONAL
SECURITY AND FOREIGN POLICY
ISSUES, AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID
HERE AND I THINK HE WENT TOO
FAR.
I THINK HE DID MISS SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT.
I DO NOT THINK HE WOULD HAVE
GONE INTO THAT CONVERSATION WITH
REPORTERS INTENDING TO
PERSONALLY BLAME PRESIDENT OBAMA
FOR ORLANDO, BUT I HAVE HEARD
HIM MAKE VARIATIONS ON THAT SAME
ARGUMENT MANY TIMES IN THE PAST,
THAT HE BLAMES OBAMA'S POLICIES
IN IRAQ FOR THE RISE OF ISIS.
MARK: I AGREE WITH YOU THAT HE
SAYS STUFF LIKE THAT ALL THE
TIME, BUT IN THIS CASE, HE FELT
COMPELLED TO TAKE IT BACK.
LET ME BRING IN OUR COLLEAGUE, A
LONGTIME MCCAIN WATCHER.
YOU HAVE HEARD HIM STAY -- SAY
PLENTY OF STUFF ABOUT OBAMA.
WHY IS THE CONTEXT DIFFERENT
HERE?
KARL: TO ME, PEOPLE ARE PLENTY
ON EDGE IN WASHINGTON OVER THIS
TRUMP THING.
I THINK HE CAME TO A QUICK
REALIZATION HE NEEDED TO TAKE
THAT BACK.
JOHN MCCAIN IS IN A TOUGH RACE
AND WILL NEED DEMOCRATS TO WIN.
HE CANNOT RELY ON DEMOCRATS IF
HE IS GOING TO GO TRASHING THE
PRESIDENT LIKE THAT, SO I THINK
THAT WAS PART OF HIS
CALCULATION, AND HE JUST KNEW HE
HAD GONE TOO FAR.
HE HAS A SENSE OF SELF, AND HE
LIKES TO SAY THESE THINGS AND BE
PROVOCATIVE, BUT HE ALSO KNOWS
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GET OUT OF
IT.
MARK: HOW TOUGH A CONTEST DOES
HE HAVE AGAINST A CONGRESSWOMAN
WHO HAS BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
CRITICIZING MCCAIN ALL ACROSS
THE BOARD, INCLUDING FOR THESE
LATEST COMMENTS?
DAN: HE HAS A VERY FORMIDABLE
OPPONENT THIS YEAR IN
KIRKPATRICK, AND I THINK THE
ATMOSPHERE AND THE BATTLEFIELD
IS TERRIBLE FOR MCCAIN WITH
TRUMP AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET.
WE HAVE A LATE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
OUR PRIMARY IS NOT UNTIL AUGUST
30, SO HE HAS TO WATCH WHAT HE
SAYS ABOUT TRUMP UNTIL AT LEAST
HE GETS THROUGH THE PRIMARY, AND
THEN I SUSPECT YOU WILL SEE
MCCAIN START TO PUT A LOT OF
DISTANCE BETWEEN HIMSELF AND
TRUMP AS HE PROCEEDS ON THIS
GENERAL ELECTION, BUT IT IS A
FRUSTRATING POSITION FOR HIM.
HE IS KIND OF STUCK IN THE
MIDDLE.
HE KIND OF LUCKED OUT A LITTLE
IN THIS PRIMARY.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
REPUBLICAN CONSERVATIVE
CONGRESSMAN THAT GROUPS LIKE
FREEDOM WORKS AND THE PUBLIC
GROWTH ARE TRYING TO PUSH INTO
THE RACE, AND THEY DECIDED NOT
TO DO SO.
HE DOES HAVE SOME PRIMARY
OPPONENTS, BUT THE GENERAL
CONSENSUS IS HE PROBABLY CAN
MAKE IT THROUGH THE PRIMARY OK.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A DIFFERENT
STORY HAD AN INCUMBENT HOUSE
MEMBER RUN AGAINST HIM.
HE IS KIND OF BIDING HIS TIME
HOPING TO GET THROUGH THIS NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
MARK: IN THE RING OF POTENTIALLY
VULNERABLE REPUBLICAN SENATE
SEATS, THAT ARIZONA SEAT IS ONE.
THE MISSOURI SEAT IS ONE.
NORTH CAROLINA.
THEN THERE IS FLORIDA WHERE
EVERY INDICATION I HAVE AND YOU
DO, TOO, THAT SENATOR RUBIO IS
GOING TO RUN -- I HEARD THAT
SENATOR RUBIO IS THINKING ABOUT
ANNOUNCE AND DENOUNCE.
HOW DOES HE SEQUENCE THAT, THAT
HE WANTS TO NOT RUN, HAVING
EMBRACED TRUMP THE WAY HE DID,
THAT HE NEEDS AT SOME POINT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT HE IS NOT
WITH TRUMP IN THE EARLY PHASES
OF CANDIDACY -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THAT?
CARL: IT IS GOING TO BE REALLY
TRICKY FOR SENATOR RUBIO IF HE
DOES DECIDE TO DO THIS.
IN SOME WAYS, AS THIS MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR SENATOR MCCAIN BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO POUR A
TON OF MONEY INTO FLORIDA.
THAT MIGHT SHIFT SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THEY WOULD USE AGAINST
MCCAIN, BUT I THINK SENATOR
RUBIO IS GOING TO HAVE A TOUGH
TIME.
ONE THING I WANTED TO SAY ABOUT
SENATOR MCCAIN ON HIS COMMENTS
-- THEY FED THIS NARRATIVE THAT
EMMA KRATZ ARE TRYING TO CREATE.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME OLD JOHN
MCCAIN YOU USED TO KNOW, THE
MAVERICK, THE STRAIGHT TALK
EXPRESS.
MCCAIN HAS CHANGED.
I THINK THAT IS REALLY HELPING
THE DEMOCRATS.
A LOT OF SENATE RACES IN THIS
CYCLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT.
MARK: OBVIOUSLY, IMMIGRATION IS
A HOT BUTTON ISSUE IN THE STATE
OF ARIZONA.
AS IT HAS BEEN PERCEIVED IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT HE IS
IN TROUBLE AND NATIONAL NUMBERS
ARE BAD, WHAT ARE ARIZONA
REPUBLICANS SAYING ABOUT THE
TRUMP CANDIDACY?
CARL: I THINK THEY ARE PRETTY
UNEASY ABOUT TRUMP AT THE TOP OF
THE TICKET.
I THINK GRADUALLY, THEY ARE
STARTING TO COME AROUND.
HE IS COMING TO TOWN ON SATURDAY
COINCIDING WITH A DEADLY HEAT
WAVE THAT IS COMING TO TOWN.
I THINK THEY ARE COMING AROUND
AND THE ARGUMENT THEY ARE MAKING
IS THAT HE IS NOT A GREAT
CONSERVATIVE BY ANY MEANS, BUT
HE IS PREFERABLE TO HILLARY
CLINTON.
THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS LIKE
SENATOR JEFF FLAKE WHO HAVE NOT
ENDORSED HIM.
MARK: OF ALL THE WASHINGTON
REPUBLICANS WITH STANDING HERE,
WHO DO YOU THINK TODAY IS BOTH
MOST UNEASY ABOUT TRUMP AND
ACTIVELY STRATEGIZING ABOUT WHAT
TO DO ABOUT IT?
CARL: I THINK MITCH MCCONNELL
OBVIOUSLY IS PLAYING THIS IN A
PRETTY INTERESTING WAY.
HE SAYS HE IS SUPPORTING THE
NOMINEE, BUT HE ALSO BASHES
TRUMP.
I THINK HE IS A GUY TO WATCH.
HE IS WATCHING THIS THROUGH THE
PRISM OF THE SUPREME COURT
VACANCIES AND HIS OWN MAJORITY.
RIGHT NOW HE THINKS IT IS IN HIS
INTEREST TO KIND OF LAY AT THE
WAY HE IS AND BE OUT THERE
SAYING, "I'M OK WITH TRUMP."
AS SOON AS HE DECIDES IT'S NOT
IN HIS INTEREST, HE IS GOING TO
NOT BE OK WITH TRUMP AND CUT HIS
INCUMBENTS LOSE.
PAUL RYAN IS HAVING A HECK OF A
TIME WITH THIS.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT SET OF
IMPERATIVES THAN MCCONNELL DOES,
BUT I'VE GOT MY EYE ON MITCH
MCCONNELL.
MARK: I DO, TOO.
IF THE TREND KEEPS GOING ON
THESE SENATE RACES THE WAY IT
IS, I THINK MCCONNELL IS GOING
TO HAVE TO COME UP WITH A NEW
STRATEGY.
IT MAY NOT MEAN TRY TO STOP
TRUMP AT THE CONVENTION, BUT IT
DOES MEAN COME UP WITH A NEW
STRATEGY OF HOW HIS INCUMBENTS
TALK ABOUT TRUMP.
CARL: HE WAS QUOTED EARLIER THIS
YEAR SAYING THEY WOULD DROP HIM
LIKE A HOT ROCK, AND I KNOW THEY
WOULD.
HE IS NOT GOING TO SIT BY AND
EASILY LOSE THE MAJORITY.
I THINK THEY HAVE REAL PROBLEMS
HANGING ONTO THEIR MAJORITY, BUT
HE WILL MAKE A MOVE IF HE HAS
TO.
MARK: DAN, YOU ARE A GREAT
STUDENT OF JOHN MCCAIN BODY
LANGUAGE.
DO YOU THINK HE IS SCARED ABOUT
LOSING THIS RACE OR JUST BEING
CAUTIOUS?
DAN: I THINK HE IS LEGITIMATELY
WORRIED, BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, HE
ALWAYS RUNS LIKE HE COULD LOSE.
THAT MAY WIND UP SAVING MCCAIN
IN THE END, THE FACT THAT HE
TOOK THIS SERIOUS FROM THE START
.
MARK: WHAT KIND OF CANDIDATE
SKILLS DOES CONGRESSWOMAN
KIRKPATRICK HAVE?
DAN: SHE IS NOT VERY WELL-KNOWN
STATEWIDE.
SHE REPRESENTS A VERY RURAL
DISTRICT, SEVERAL INDIAN
COMMUNITIES IN HER DISTRICT, SO
SHE HAS TO GET HERSELF KNOWN A
LITTLE MORE IN MARICOPA COUNTY
WHERE MOST OF THE VOTERS ARE,
BUT SHE IS A THREE-TERM HOUSE
MEMBER.
SHE WAS DEFEATED IN 2010 AND HAS
BEEN REELECTED TWO MORE TIMES
SINCE THEN.
SHE SUPPORTED THE AFFORD OF A
CARE ACT, WHICH IS A MCCAIN
ISSUE.
THAT IS WHAT MCCAIN IS AFTER HER
ON AND SHE IS AFTER HIM ON
BUILDING THE FENCE.
SOMETHING MCCAIN HAS A BIG
ENOUGH BRAND ON HIS OWN TO
OVERCOME THIS.
BUT EVERYONE KNOWS THIS IS GOING
TO BE JOHN MCCAIN'S TOUGHEST
RACE.
SOME PEOPLE THINK ARIZONA IS IN
PLAY.
THAT WILL NOT BE GOOD FOR HIM.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO KEEP HIS
COMPOSURE, THOUGH, I THINK, AND
HE RECOGNIZES THAT.
MARK: EASIER SAID THAN DONE WHEN
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT JOHN
MCCAIN.
UP NEXT, A DEBATE THAT HAS BEEN
RAGING FOR MONTHS.
WE WILL PARSE OUT DONALD TRUMP'S
WORDS SYLLABLE BY SYLLABLE WHEN
WE COME BACK.
♪
MARK: FINALLY TONIGHT, AND ISSUE
DIVIDING AMERICA IN A BIGLY WAY
-- OR IS IT A BIG LEAGUE WAY?
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT, HERE'S HOW TO GET
CAUGHT UP --
TRUMP: SOMEDAY, I BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE PROVEN OUT BIGLY.
>> TWITTER SAYS LOL.
THEN TWITTER SAYS SLOWDOWN.
I CAN NEVER TELL IF HE IS SAYING
"BIGLY" OR "BIG LEAGUE."
>> YOU HIT ME, I'LL HIT YOU BACK
BIGLY.
>> PEOPLE ON TV ALSO DISAGREE.
THE WORLD MAY NEVER KNOW.
MARK: IT IS TRUE WE MAY NEVER
KNOW, BUT LET'S TURN NOW TO OUR
BIGLY BIG-LEAGUE DECISION DESK.
WHAT ARE YOU FINDING?
>> THE OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
SUPPORTS THE BIGLY CONCLUSION.
TRUMP HAS NOT SAID THE LEAGUE.
YOU WOULD HEAR THE G AT THE END
OF THAT WITH A CASE.
TRUMP: ABSOLUTELY, THERE IS AN
ASSAULT ON CHRISTIANITY, AND WE
ARE GOING TO REVERSE THAT TREND
BIGLY.
>> I DID NOT HEAR AG AT THE END
AT ALL.
>> CLEARLY, BIG LEAGUE.
TRUMP HAS A WELL-KNOWN HABIT OF
DROPPING HIS G'S.
JUST ASK LYIN' TED.
MARK: WHAT IS THE CAMPAIGN
SAYING ON THE RECORD ABOUT THIS?
>> SAYING IT IS BIG LEAGUE.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE HER WORD
FOR IT?
SHE SAYS THE RNC HAS A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
MARK: THE DEBATE CONTINUES.
WE'LL STAY ON IT AND BRING YOU
THE LATEST THROUGHOUT THE
PROGRAM.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: THANKS TO OUR TRIO OF
COHOST TODAY.
CHECK OUT BLOOMBERGPOLITICS.COM
FOR A STORY ON COMPANIES OPTING
OUT OF THE CONVENTION.
THIS HAVING AN EFFECT ON
DEMOCRATS AS WELL.
COMING UP, TALKING ABOUT THE
INTERSECTION OF TERRORISM AND
SOCIAL MEDIA -- A TIMELY TOPIC,
AS THEY SAY.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.
WE WILL BE BACK HERE NEXT WEEK,
SAME BAT TIME, SAME BAT CHANNEL.
UNTIL MONDAY, SAYONARA.
♪
>> I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
LET'S START WITH A CHECK OF YOUR
FIRST WORD NEWS.
SECRETARY CARTER IS BASHING THE
REBEL FORCES IN SOUTHERN SYRIA.
HE SAID THEY WERE FIGHTING
SECRETARY STATE.
HE CALLED RUSSIA'S ACTION
PROBLEMATIC.
THEY MISUSED A CHANNEL THAT'S
INTENDED TO GET AIR FORCES OVER
SYRIA.
GOVERNMENT FORCES HAVE GAINED
CONTROL OVER MOST OF FA LUGEA.
-- FALUGA.
HIS TROOPS CONTROL ABOUT 80% OF
THE CITY WITH ISLAMIC STATE
MILITANTS ON THE CITY'S NORTHERN
EDGE.
THE VOICE AND DATA RECORDERS
FROM THE EGYPT AIRPLANE THAT
CRASH INTO THE MEDITERRANEAN ARE
EXTENSIVELY DAMAGED AND WILL
NEED REPAIRS BEFORE THEY CAN BE
ANALYZED.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE
"ASSOCIATED PRESS."
SEARCHERS RECOVERED THE SECOND
BLACK BOX TODAY IN THE QUAKE OF
THE FLORIDA MASSACRES, THEY
HOIST REPUBLICANS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT BE ALLOWED TO PREVENT
ANYONE ON A TERRORIST WATCH LIST
FROM BUYING A GUN.
REPUBLICANS DISAGREE.
THEY SAID A COURT SHOULD HAVE TO
SIGN OFF ON NO-BUY ORDER.
FROM BLOOMBERG WORLD
HEADQUARTERS IN NEW YORK, I'M
MARK CRUMPTON.
>> THIS IS "BLOOMBERG WEST."
APPLE FACING THE THREAT OF A
SALE FREEZE.
HOW SERIOUS ARE THE ALLEGATIONS?
WE'RE BREAK THEM DOWN.
BILL GATES SITS DOWN EXCLUSIVELY
AND HEAR HIS VIEWS ON THE LINKED
IN DEAL.
AND HOLLYWOOD DIPS ITS TOES IN
VIRTUAL REALITY AND WHY THE
GAMING INDUSTRY IS STILL SITTING
ON THE SIDELINES.
APPLE HIT WITH A PATENT DISPUTE
IN CHINA.
THE BEIJING INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY OFFICE HAS FOUND THAT
THE IPHONE 6 AND 6 PLUS ARE TOO
SIMILAR TO THE CHINESE BAILI.
APPLE QUICKLY FIRED-BACK.
ALL ARE GEARING OUT TO ROLL OUT
THE NEXT MODEL.
R.B.C. JOINED J.P. MORGAN FOR
THE STOCK.
SO HOW BIG A DEAL IS THIS?
REALLY.